I collect a lot of maps and sometimes I
get asked like what makes a good map to
buy or collect and I have one key answer
the only thing I look for when I'm
buying a map is how beautiful it is like
do I like looking at it this is a map
that is freaking gorgeous
seriously like it's just beautiful and I
like looking at it and I like staring at
it and I like reading all the little
things and looking at all the details
and how the borders are drawn and how
the depth of the ocean is rendered and
it's just gorgeous so to me maths are
information but they're also art and
they're beautiful and if you like
looking at it then that's a map that you
should have